This is it.
Here we all are, together at last,
to talk about optimism.
If this isn't nice, I don't know what is.
Here's the problem: it's 2021.
We are living through a global plague,
one that revealed our worst instincts
at the worst times.
We are so divided that public health
has become a power struggle.
We pioneered a vaccine,
a moon-landing level innovation,
and then kept it among wealthy countries
while poor ones suffered.
Against this backdrop,
isn't talking about optimism,
like discussing pagers
or horse-drawn carriages?
Isn't optimism obsolete,
backwards and naive,
given all we've been through?
Shouldn't it be replaced
with a more up-to-date
cognitive technology?
Well, lots of people
have replaced it with cynicism:
the notion that humanity is greedy,
selfish and dishonest.
In 1972, 45 percent of Americans
thought that most people can be trusted.
By 2018, that had dropped
to about 30 percent.
We are living through a cynicism epidemic.
I should know --
last year, it infected me,
and I'm supposed to be immune.
I'm a psychologist and neuroscientist,
and my whole career, I've studied
the sunny side of human nature.
My lab and I have found
that giving away money
activates similar parts of your brain
as eating chocolate,
and that helping other people
through their stress calms our own.
Our punch line is clear:
there is good in us,
and it does good for us.
Now, people love hearing this,
but in 2020, I started to hate saying it.
I was building hope in others
while losing my own.
I was evangelizing
for human kindness all day
and then doomscrolling at night.
I was peddling something
that I would never want to buy anymore.
I felt like a fraud,
or, at best, maybe a fax-machine salesman.
(Laughter)
But here's the thing.
You might think that cynicism
is a system upgrade
that allows us to see who we really are.
It's not.
It traps us in a version of the world
we don't want to live in,
and one we don't have to.
One of my favorite studies of all time
occurred in southeastern Brazil.
Two fishing villages there
are separated by just 30 miles.
One sits by the ocean,
where fishing requires
large boats and heavy equipment.
To make a living there,
fishermen must work together.
The other sits by a lake,
where fishermen strike out
alone on small boats
and compete with one another.
Years ago,
researchers tested how people
in each of these villages
responded to a set of social experiments.
Ocean fishermen trusted strangers
and cooperated with their neighbors.
Lake fishermen competed
and mistrusted instead.
But here's the crazy part.
These folks didn't start out
any different from each other,
but the longer fishermen
worked on the lake,
the more they competed.
The longer they worked
on the ocean, the less they did.
Some families, schools and companies
are like ocean villages.
People trust, because they know
others will earn it.
Some are like lake towns --
people look out for themselves,
because no one else will.
Our social worlds shape us, like clay,
into hopeful or cynical
versions of ourselves.
And right now,
many of us are living
in a lake town of historic proportion.
Inequality has soared,
injustice is all around,
self-interest might as well be pumped
into the water supply.
These forces raise cynicism,
and so do times of disaster.
After the last 18 months,
there's a real chance we could
tip into a sort of cynical permafrost.
Now,
I'm going to guess there may be
some proud cynics in the audience today,
and you might be thinking, "Good.
More people should turn to the dark side.
Optimism might feel nice --
so would calling tiramisu a health food,
but we don't get to go around
believing whatever we like."
George Bernard Shaw tells us
that the power of accurate observation
is commonly called "cynicism"
by those who haven't got it.
(Laughter)
107 years later,
the cartoon philosopher Lisa Simpson
taught us that as intelligence goes up,
happiness goes down.
Maybe hope does, too.
Maybe cynicism
is the price of being right.
Most people think so.
70 percent think cynics
are smarter than noncynics;
85 percent think they would make
better lie detectors.
Most people are wrong.
It turns out that cynics
tend to perform less well than noncynics
on cognitive tests.
They earn less money,
and they lose more often in negotiations.
They're not even good
at spotting bad guys.
In one study,
researchers conducted mock job interviews,
asking half the candidates to lie
and half to tell the truth.
Cynics and noncynics watched videos
of these interviews
and guessed who was lying.
And cynics did way worse.
More generally, they assume
liars are everywhere
so can't pick real ones out of a crowd.
So cynicism might not be
as smart as you think it is,
but it's still powerful,
because our stories about each other
become self-fulfilling.
Cynics are more likely
to refuse intimacy and cooperation.
They hurt others to avoid being hurt.
They tend to spy on their colleagues
and suspect their friends,
and other people,
unsurprisingly, react badly --
sometimes, acting selfishly in response.
In other words, by mistreating others,
cynics create the exact
conditions they fear.
They tell a story full of villains
and end up living in it.
I call this the cynicism trap,
and my lab explores ways
that people fall into it.
In one study, we asked people
how happiness works.
Some thought that it's a zero-sum game,
meaning that as one person's
happiness goes up,
another person's must go down.
Now they're wrong.
It turns out that when we act
generously towards others,
that tends to increase our happiness.
But cynics acted on their illusion.
When given chances to help strangers,
they were less likely to do so.
They ended up less happy as well.
By hoarding well-being,
they lost out on one
of its key ingredients --
other people.
In other work,
we asked Republicans and Democrats
what it would mean to empathize
with the other side.
Some people saw politics as a war,
and thought empathy would be as useful
as bringing cotton candy to a gunfight.
These folks didn't want to cooperate
with the other side,
or even to know them at all.
In one study,
we measured college students'
cynicism about empathy
and asked about the friends
they made on campus.
Here, each dot is a person,
coded blue to red based on ideology,
and each line is a friendship.
Now, this was a pretty liberal campus,
but nonetheless, noncynics managed to find
ideologically diverse friends.
Cynics stuck to their own kind.
Now that's, of course, their right.
But most of us wish
our country was less divided,
and empathy is critical
to moving us towards that goal.
By giving up on it,
cynics lose that chance.
Our studies and many others
give us a clear picture
of the cynicism trap.
When we decide
everyone's out for themselves,
we stop seeing their kindness.
When we think the world is zero-sum,
everyone becomes a potential enemy.
These views spread across us, too.
Parents pass on
their suspicions to their kids.
Politicians act in bad faith
and damage voters' faith in each other.
Media companies trade
in judgment and outrage.
Our cynicism is their product,
and it is a growth industry.
So no, cynicism doesn't help us
see reality more clearly,
but it does change reality,
poisoning our relationships,
our lives and our culture.
It is not a system upgrade,
it's mental malware.
But we don't have to accept it.
We can take control of our stories.
To escape the cynicism trap, we have to.
My lab tries to help.
In one study,
we taught people that happiness
is not a zero-sum game,
and that helping others helps us, too.
These folks, compared to those
in a cynical condition,
donated more to charity afterwards,
and they ended up happier as well.
In other work, we changed how people
thought about empathy in politics.
Some people were randomly chosen
to read a cynical essay.
It began, and I'm paraphrasing,
"You might think empathy is a weakness
that will make you lose every argument,
and you'd be right."
Afterwards, we asked these folks
to write a note about gun control
to someone they disagreed with,
and they sniped at each other.
Here’s a voice actor reading
what one Democrat wrote to a Republican.
Recording: “It’s hard
not to state this bluntly.
You should be in favor
of stricter gun laws
because you should care
about the lives of other people
more than your outdated
feelings of machismo."
Jamil Zaki: And here’s a Republican
writing to a Democrat.
Recording: "People need to know
they're able to have
the freedom to bear arms
in order to protect themselves.
You democrats don't get to take
that away from us."
JZ: Basically, we recreated
Twitter, by accident.
(Laughter)
Other people read a different essay.
It began,
"You might think empathy is a weakness
that will make you lose every argument,
and you'd be wrong."
... and went on to describe empathy
as a strength in politics.
Again, we asked these folks
to write to an opponent about gun control,
but this time, things changed.
Here’s a Democrat.
Recording: "There are some
common-sense regulations
that we should implement
to keep people safe.
We all want what is best for the country,
and there are things we can meet
in the middle on
to tackle the issue of gun violence."
JZ: And a Republican.
Recording: "Horrible crimes
can be committed using guns ...
everything from school shootings
to murders because of racism
and white supremacy.
It's very understandable
that you think it makes sense
to make gun laws more strict.
We're all reasonable people,
and we just want what's best
for our loved ones."
JZ: To us, this was wild.
Remember,
just like ocean and lake fishermen,
these people did not
start out any different,
but just reading one essay
turned some of them into new optimists
and others into new cynics.
This shaped how they acted,
and their effect on other people.
We sent all of these notes
to people who really disagreed
with the writer about gun control,
and found that notes
written by new optimists
were more persuasive
than those written by new cynics,
more likely to make other people
change their mind.
In other words,
we taught these people
that empathy was useful,
they used it, and it became useful.
This is what I want you to remember
and what I want you to know:
that if cynical stories
can become self-fulfilling,
our work shows
that hopeful ones can as well.
Now, cynicism is not the only
root of our problems,
and optimism alone will not fix them.
But it's hard to change a broken system
if you think it's a mirror
reflecting our broken nature.
If people are selfish to our core,
then toxic laws and practices
are here to stay.
But we can all choose
to tell a different story.
We can be skeptical --
demanding evidence
before we believe in people --
but hopeful, knowing
they can change for the better.
We can notice their kindness
even when the media doesn’t
and envision systems
built on that kindness.
We can find other people
in our neighborhoods,
unions and faith communities
who want the same thing.
We can use our collective optimism
to build pockets of solidarity
and mutual aid,
miniature ocean villages
that can grow over time.
Now, this is the part of the talk
where I'm supposed to tell you
how I cured my own cynicism.
But the truth is, I still struggle.
Depending on the day or the hour,
I promise, I can be as cynical
as anyone here.
But I see cynicism for what it is --
a psychological quicksand
that will pull me in deeper,
the more I move through it.
So I fight to believe in people,
not because it feels good,
but because stories matter,
and we're telling ours
all the time, together.
We all get stuck in quicksand --
sometimes, that's OK.
But the next time
you manage to pull yourself out,
and find some faith in humanity,
try to remember to reach back
and grab someone else who's stuck,
until more of us
can make it to solid ground.
Because optimism
is not a relic of the past.
It's one key to building a better future
by letting us see it more clearly.
Thank you.
(Applause)